my life
hasn't been what you probably think it
has
we all have our struggles have you ever
been in love
a long long time ago
you so many times yeah all the time
welcome to the future life is good
but it can be better
and why shouldn't it be
all you need is to want it!
think about finally having everything
you always wanted
I can save today
but you can save the world
Steve?
now I take what I want in return
everyone will see
the world needs you
you know you need to do
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
it's all art
it's uh that's just a trash can it's
just a trash can yeah yeah
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new wonder woman 1984
trailer video they just released a brand
new prequel story for the movie that
explains
what's going on and why everything is so
crazy in the trailer
in a bunch of wonder woman justice
league snyder cut stuff in addition
separately and wonder woman dc future
movies spin-offs and tv shows that
they're working on
so we'll break it all down there's a lot
of big dc stuff happening right now
because we're heading into that big dc
fandom comic con panel and i'll be doing
videos for all that stuff too because
they'll be dropping a bunch of footage
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with wonder woman after wonder woman
1984.
i'll just number these as we go along
just to stay organized but the first big
thing
is the prequel story that they just
released for wonder woman 1984
is how it connects with what's going on
with cheetah the wonder woman character
steve trevor coming back with his
special little fanny pack there
walking around in the trailer and
maxwell lord who's supposed to be the
villain of the movie
but since this is happening in 1984
there's no justice league yet
superman in the man of steel movie
hasn't even crashed earth in his pod
that's around 1986 since he's about 27
during man of steel
fun fact though if we're talking about
justice league connections here batman's
parents were killed in crime alley when
he was about eight years old canonically
if this movie is taking place in 1984
then ben affleck's batman would have
already lost his parents a couple years
earlier if he's supposed to be around 42
or so during batman v superman
we don't know exactly what the year is
going to be for robert pattinson's the
batman movie so i can't say a hundred
percent when he was born but he's
supposed to be a younger version of the
character
but it's not connected to the wonder
woman movies or to justice league the
justice league snyder cut or any of that
stuff so don't worry too much about the
timeline for the batman movie we'll talk
about that when they start releasing
more batman trailers
but in this big wonder woman 1984 movie
prequel story that they just released
she's been working at the smithsonian in
washington dc for a while
putting out some small fires she's still
wonder woman she's still helping people
out but it's much smaller scale there
aren't any major wars that she's
participated in in the last year or so
heading into the movie
it's really during the events of the
movie that things go into global
catastrophe mode
they're not retconning anything during
this movie so the justice league
timeline all the pre-existing wonder
woman movie story that you've seen
through batman v superman the first
wonder woman movie that's all still
valid
so eventually in the future she goes to
work for the louvre in paris like we saw
during batman v superman or during the
first wonder woman movie
but the big thing about the prequel
story that they just revealed is it
explains what the dream stone
is and how it fits into the wonder woman
mythology is an object created by one of
the greek gods
the dream stone is the special black
rock that you see in all the trailers
they implied that ares killed most of
the other greek gods in that big
flashback scene in the first
wonderbombing movie this big rebellion
happened when zeus was creating
themschira
but if aerys survived the present day
now it's implied that other gods also
survived to present day
here's the big thing about the movie
even though a lot of people had early
theories about where maxwell lord gets
his power from because of how he works
in the comics
there aren't any actual gods played by
other characters
supposed to be in the movie there's no
secret god like ares in the first movie
hiding out wearing the skin of a human
pretending to be normal pulling the
strings or anything like that
but during the prequel story there's
this whole subplot about people stealing
antiquities and special items with power
that are headed to the smithsonian for
wonder woman and barbara minerva to
investigate and catalog
we learned that barbara minerva is just
another archaeologist working at the
smithsonian that wonder woman
befriends and she starts to idealize her
one of the special items that winds up
getting stolen
is the special black rock and it's just
maxwell lord manipulating the dreamstone
and cheetah that explains why everything
goes completely crazy during the movie
so technically he does wind up using
power of the gods it's just that you
never really see
who that god is they never really
explain which god created the dream
stone
but it is exactly what it sounds like it
has the ability to grant
one of your wishes or deepest desires
making it come true
but it's a big monkey's paw situation
and the way they balance the story
is that the god power of the dreamstone
doesn't just create something out of
nothing law of equal exchange
when you use its power it also takes
something of equal value from you
so number three this is what explains
cheetah becoming full-blown comic book
cheetah and steve trevor
coming back during the movie and even
wonder woman wearing that special golden
armor
because there are all kinds of fan
theories about what's going on when this
was first revealed
people thought that it was hades
bringing steve trevor back from the
underworld because we're talking greek
gods here
people thought that he was martian
manhunter for a little while pretending
to be steve trevor
so he's real he's full on back to life
none the worst for wear
and it's all because wonder woman
accidentally uses the dreamstone's power
without realizing what the consequences
are
you have to give up something in order
for the power to work its magic
wonder woman and cheetah's wishes sort
of overlap with
each other and maxwell lord is trying to
manipulate both of them so notice how
awkward
cheetah seems when she's talking to
wonder woman at the beginning of the
trailer here
she's still full on barbara minerva but
then later in the trailer and these
pictures
she mysteriously gets super hot and
super confident in herself
then at the end of the movie gets more
and more powerful eventually turning
into full-blown cheetah monster form
from the comics
it's the cheetah wishes early in the
movie that she could be just like wonder
woman
so because it's a comic book movie of
course the dream stone literally
makes her like wonder woman and in order
to get steve trevor back to life the
dream stone takes
wonder woman's power from her
simultaneously giving it
to cheetah and that sort of explains why
wonder woman has to wear that special
suit of golden armor from the comics
so number two more steve trevor as you
can see there's a moment in the trailer
this kind of explains what's going on
when wonder woman is freaking out and
steve trevor tells her you know
what you have to do this is wonder woman
after she's lost her power she has to
take her wish
back reversing steve trevor so that he
goes back to being dead and gone
but in exchange she gets all of her
powers back and she can finally stop
cheetah and maxwell lord
the reason why it seems like she's
flying into thin air is just because
she's lassoing a regular airplane and
they hadn't finished the visual effects
on the trailer when they released this
still pretty cool scene it's just kind
of misleading the way you see it during
the trailer but most trailers are like
that
it's the same situation where it seems
like she's lassoing the lightning bolts
in these really crazy trailer scenes
here it's just that there's a lot of
unfinished special effects and visual
effects here
the number one the whole thing with
wonder woman in the justice league
snyder cut as you saw from the last big
snyder cut trailer they released
is there's a ton more subplot and story
with her character in her history
incorporated to the dark side parts of
the movie they fight him off but this is
all happening before wonder woman is
born so she's learning about this for
the first time in this scene here
there's also a ton more wonder woman and
present day running around during the
alternate story lines with the other
characters
you have to imagine that the snyder cut
is going to be over four hours long
so it's almost like they're adding an
entire new movie or even
two movies into what we originally saw
but all this justice league snyder cut
stuff
isn't connected to the other spin-offs
in future wonder woman projects that
patty jenkins has been talking about
so obviously they're doing wonder woman
three but patty jenkins was also working
on a spin-off wonder woman movie she
said that's on hold right now
and she also recently said that they're
developing an animated wonder woman tv
show but no idea when that would
premiere but it would be an hbo max
show so most of the really big new dc
series that they're developing
are for hbo max there's supposed to be a
much longer justice league snyder cut
trailer at the big dc
fandom comic con panel that zack snyder
is doing next month
there's also a special justice league
convention that he's doing this month in
july so he'll also probably reveal some
new details deleted scenes and story
lines that he's adding back in
so whatever that is i'll do videos for
that stuff too while you wait for
everything click here for that really
cool video of henry cavill building
himself a gaming pc for the first time
during the quarantine
and click here for that last big justice
league snyder cut trailer that they
released
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!